[Música]
si uno necesita algo que no lo puede
comprar con mlc o con moneda nacional
pues ellos lo tienen entonces son cosas
que uno necesita
[Música]
yo sostengo que se ha pasado de la noche
al día en lo que
al capacidades de desempeño para el
sector privado se entiende en Cuba desde
el punto de vista legal el cambio ha
sido
absoluto y total Aunque hay muchas cosas
por cambiar
[Música]
la idea de formar rdc surge a partir de
la prueba pandemia éramos tres socios
los tres éramos trabajadores de del
sector y el restaurante donde no donde
trabajábamos
y realmente con todo este problema de la
pandemia estamos todos cerrados
encontramos un lecho en el mercado de
hacer algo un poco diferente a lo que se
estaba haciendo
[Música]